with the observer design pattern if an
object is modified it broadcasts to
dependent objects that a change has
occurred one example is the
model-view-controller architecture when
the view updates the model changes event
handlers are another example of the
observer design pattern these are
functions that will be notified when a
certain event fires when you use the add
event listener function in JavaScript
you would basically using the observer
pattern this is very similar to the
publication subscription pattern now
here is a UML diagram from Wikipedia
that kind of explains that the pattern
so we have a subject right here now a
subject maintains a list of observers
and facilitates adding or removing
observers so you can register new
observers you can unregister or
subscribe and unsubscribe you can also
uh notify the observers and when you
notify the observers it's going to you
look down here to the function
definition a for observer and observer
collection and call observer notify so
it's going to call notify for each
observer this is the the overall
observer and then you you can make
instances of the observer confidence
over a calculate River B and so then on
the submenu call notify observers it's
going to call this function so each
observer is notified let's go back and
look at some actual code so here's the
definition of the subject and we are
going to create an observer array
there's four different functions in the
in the subject we have subscribe
observer where we're just going to pass
in an observer object and then push that
observer object onto the array then we
have unsubscribed observer where weight
basically we just find the observer
objects and try to find the index of the
observer object they passed in and then
we're going to splice the or this is
basically just taking out the observer
from the array and we notify observers
this is where we can just notify one
observer we pass in the observer we find
the index and then we're going to call
the the observer that notify on the
index number of the observer we passed
and so only one observer is being
notified
then we have notify all observers where
we're basically going to notify every
observer
that array observers dot length it's a
four for loop and I'm going to go
through each each observer in the array
and notify so let's go down and look at
what the observer looks like now this is
a pretty basic example of an observer
and the main thing about the observer is
that you need to have a notify function
in this case we're just going to console
that log observer and then the number of
the observer is notified but obviously
in a real example you'll probably do
something a little more detailed than
this but let's go down to where we
create the objects so we're gonna create
a new subject object that was the first
one we reviewed up there and then of our
observer 1 equals new observer 1 now
here we'll just we can pass in things
when recurring the observer here we're
just passing in the number of the
observer and main reason for that so you
can see in the console what number is
being notified so we're creating the for
observers now we're going to subscribe
all these observers are going to
subscribe so subject that subscribed the
observer and observer one two three four
now I take off the the comment for this
so we have subject that notify observer
observer two so if we run that you can
see just observer two is notified and
now I'm gonna do something else when I
subject that unsubscribe now observer
two is been unsubscribe and now we're
going to take off this comment subject
that notify all observers and we run
that so this is the first thing we got
from the notify observer observer two
and then this is what happened with the
notify all observers we have their
observer 1 3 & 4 you can see observer 2
was not notified because it's been
unsubscribed well that's just a basic
example of the observer pattern thanks
for watching my name is Bo Carnes don't
forget to subscribe and remember use
your code for good